I'm very sure Peter why do you want
crazy
I don't want crazy Peter you said you
did I that's the hunter hey saying that
That's not me I was just singing along
the lyrics okay I listen our
relationship with with my with Victoria
it was very real there was a lot of
crazy there I think I said once with
Hannah brown
like a little bit crazy as fun just a
little bit not a lot I swear watching
things back with Victoria a lot of
people have said look this is really
dysfunctional how are you feeling
watching it back anything you would do
differently what's just your take on it
I think you saw a relationship there
that definitely required a lot of work
and we could have definitely easily
given up really early on and it would
have been a lot easier for probably both
of us but I think there's something
beautiful and that we didn't and even
though there's a lot of opinions about
people that think we should never have
been together we fought and fought and
fought and I think till the end even
though it wasn't us in the end I thought
there was something beautiful of that
relationship and how what it got the
point it got to and what we learned
about ourselves and just being able to
communicate a lot better I appreciate
[Music]
this is really good for us
it's probably the best Victoria F
surprised everybody tonight she came in
communicating clearly speaking her mind
we loved watching it how did you feel
seeing what couldn't feel like a
different woman out there yeah that was
a very beautiful thing for me to see and
there's you know even if maybe you don't
find your person throughout this it's
only gonna work for hopefully two people
there was a lot to be learned and I feel
like I learned a lot too but seeing that
with Victoria just it made me so happy
to see her in a good spot and you know
she deserves love just like every single
person here let me ask you also about
Victoria F how did you guys as a group
of women feel having watched turn Peter
have kind of a dysfunctional level of
communication you know it's crazy
because in the house me and Victoria
we're really close I love that girl and
she and how she presented herself today
like is amazing that's exactly who I
know she is so when I was watching it
back I was just like wow like what's
happening like and you could you could
see that it's a struggle for her and
that she is trying to like put up those
walls but she did I'm happy with how she
handled herself today she did faint
amazing she did amazing let me ask you -
I mean something that wasn't brought up
at you being friends with her and she
apologized for it on social media but
the white lives matter thing and I never
and I I honestly don't think that she
had an idea that that was what it was
I've never had anything with her I mean
clearly even with her like she's she's
not like blonde hair blue eyed you know
what I mean so it's kind of just like I
never got anything from her in a sense
of where I was offended by her at all
ever and so I just don't think that she
you know is it was unintentional I think
that Victoria F is just one of those
pure people that I mean communications
heart and communication is hard for
everybody it's just a very difficult
thing like nobody likes being put in
uncomfortable situations and sometimes
communicating your emotions and your
feelings is really hard and so in this
environment it's even harder so I can't
fault her and I'm really proud of Peter
for being so patient with her and really
taking the time to be like listen I want
to hear from you I want to know what
you're feeling just talk to me Victoria
Poehler is an incredible woman and is
one of my close friends and so I'm
really proud of her for tonight
I think there are old with you I mean I
think we were all just so surprised
because she communicates quite well did
you know she had that in her what
happened during filming of the show I'll
say that many of us I think and when the
cameras are around and there's a lot of
pressure and everyone's dating the same
guy it's really easy to kind of fall
back I know for myself and times of
confrontation I just was like and you
see that on camera you know it's it's
hard to address everything and to be
completely wholesome
[Music]